[Music]
remember when monday mornings were like
[Music]
this
they're a bit different now
[Music]
while those of us lucky to be working
are now doing so from a spare bedroom or
kitchen table
the coronavirus has forced a sudden and
mostly successful pivot to working away
from the office
while the circumstances are unwelcome
there are some benefits
to this style of working you have a more
content
workforce more motivated workforce and
and also a more productive and efficient
workforce as well
so when the coronavirus is behind us
will our workday ever be the same again
[Music]
we spend a lot of our time traveling to
work and for most
the commute is getting longer all over
the world
globally two-fifths of professionals
consider the commute to be the worst
part of their day
commuting has been found to be a major
cause for stress
that impacts on our physiological health
and
as well well-being the total working day
gets longer you get
less time at home you do less exercises
when you have long commutes you also
cook less healthy food i followed
swedish couples over a 10-year period
and
we found that commuting long distances
to work over one hour
increases the risk of separation overall
we find that it's a
40 increase of risk of separating
before the pandemic approximately 25
million u.s workers spent more than 90
minutes
getting to and from their jobs every day
in south korea one in four workers has a
journey that long
one of those people is park john pan a
manager at a major telecoms company
basically i throw away three hours of my
day time
just to get to work and to come back
home
since february sk telecom has instructed
its employees
including yong han to work from home or
if suitable
to work from smaller local offices in
the surrounding neighborhoods of seoul
one of the mobile offices if i walk it
takes about 15 minutes
i truly appreciate the time and and it
actually
comes back to motivation to to work
harder it's not just time
it's a very quality time that i spent
instead of you know getting stuck in a
bus you know
get stuck in a traffic somewhere it's it
cannot compare
the amount of time that i spent with my
family really increased
you know during lunch time i can have
lots of time with my son
have you just shortened your hours and
you're able to go and like you said
exercise more or do you find yourself
working more as a result
because it's been too long i totally
forgot about it
but in the very beginning when this
program started
um i was exhausted actually uh
during the first few days because there
is no place for
for rest right because i i need to work
anywhere wherever i go um
my mind was always on work and when i
talked to
the teammates they actually felt the
same in the beginning
but after a few weeks um i i think
everyone found
their own way to work and now i know how
to adjust
you know myself into you know work mode
versus you know
rest mode and so on
so losing that journey into work could
be good for us
but research claims our commute can also
provide us with a means to separate our
personal
and professional lives and in a world of
10 second
bed to laptop commutes that's a chance
for some me time
but while journey times were already
generally on the up
more of us were actually starting to
commute less
thanks to a relatively new trend
flexible working
increasingly we have seen people remote
working from lots of different locations
there has been a reluctance to encourage
flexible working
perhaps because managers see it as a
loss of control
it can be quite difficult to manage
people who you don't necessarily see
on a day-to-day basis there might be
concerns around
efficiency or productivity
and is that a bit of a myth or is any of
that borne out in fact
what we've found is that productivity
can actually
improve as a result of flexible working
and there isn't necessarily any impact
upon the business if it's managed
effectively
there's quite a lot of benefits there is
an opportunity for workers to have more
autonomy over their scheduling over when
they work and where they work
and when people have that degree of
autonomy it does lead
to a workforce that is happier you may
have flexibility over the time that you
have to go into work or the time that
you can come home
so that you're able to avoid rush hour
traffic
and if you're working from home a few
days a week or
completely at home then obviously you
can avoid the commuting altogether
and there's also benefits for employers
a study by harvard and new york
university found that for those working
from home the workday is 48 minutes
longer
probably replacing that time you spent
commuting there's
significant benefits for organizations
that are able to manage
these kind of processes effectively so
what actions can
organizations implement to harness the
power of flexible working
they need to have very clear processes
and procedures
around operating flexible work so that
everybody has the same
expectations one department allows
um the majority of their employees to
work flexibly in another department
which is led by another
line manager who has a different view
then
you might find that flexible working
isn't as supported
as much you need to treat people
consistently and in a fair way but you
also need to recognize that there can be
individual differences in how people
adapt to flexible working it will some
suit some people but not
others so you do need to have a degree
of flexibility yourself as a manager
in how you manage teams and how you
manage people
and this flexibility can lead to
productivity
a two-year stanford study of a thousand
employees at one company
found that working from a home office
resulted in a 13
increase in productivity and 50 percent
of them
were less likely to quit despite this
half of them still wanted to go back to
the office nine months later
even though their average commute was 40
minutes each way
another survey conducted by bain and
company on its own employees
found that productivity increased for
some thanks to no commute
and an ability to focus better at home
but also
decreased for others due to a lack of
work mindset
and a dedicated workspace so perhaps
we'll start to see a more hybrid style
become the norm
where for some days we work from home
for specific solo tasks
and others we travel to the office to
meet and collaborate with the team
the changing nature of our working lives
has already led to many white collar
workers leaving the city or moving
further out
to find more space some greenery or to
escape the urban beeps and bustle
one person who misses the commute is
alice shea an
urban planner and designer i miss riding
the subway
uh riding the subway is one of those
incredible
experiences in new york city it's got a
ties it's got its lows
but honestly the subway system in new
york city is one of the
greatest levers for equity that we have
it is one price to get
all the way across the city many of us
are now working from home
you know or at least for a couple of
days of the week will
where we live drastically change do you
think
we're in a moment where commutes can be
zero so
what does that mean for how we are
distributed across our
settlements and urban agglomerations i
think it provides a lot of flexibility
for certain workers it's true
but there's other ties that keep people
to place right it's not just about
commute so that's one factor amongst
many
access to services access to family um
access to
the you know the culture that keeps the
city alive or
your lifestyle interesting so the the
city as we know it isn't exactly
going anywhere but uh it might change in
the way that we
use it and the the way it works our uh
street infrastructure and streetscapes
can be reconfigured
in a time of social distancing when
we're understanding that private cars
may not be as essential as we thought
they were
we posited that if you took the
streetscape in manhattan which is
equivalent to
four times the size of central park
reconfigured it in a way that actually
looked at streetscapes as being about
space for mobility and distribution at a
bigger scale
so how do we actually decrease the
number of cars and what are the
opportunities that come with that so
increased space for pedestrians and
walking more effective
uh distribution systems buses could run
at least twice as fast
getting people around the city in an
equitable way
the transformation of the way that we
use our streetscapes could also
enable better delivery of urban systems
is there an opportunity to
to build more equality in cities
you know key workers for instance who
who aren't doing jobs on a laptop right
now they
have to be in those areas don't they you
know no matter what i mean you bring up
a great point service workers essential
workers
they are geographically bound mobile
healthcare could be distributed
more widely more equitably particularly
if
there's government and public drivers
behind the way that that is distributed
we're also seeing massive changes in the
way that retail is happening
right many many shops are closed
when we have times when cities are more
porous when there's flux
when you know real estate sector isn't
so saturated
that porousness allows for an
opportunity for micro entrepreneurship
and also um new innovations
at a kind of small scale um you know
small businesses that are starting up
food trucks that are going to be
distributing food across the city
um different types of services that
operate in different types of places
[Music]
our changing relationship with work
could affect where we live too
it could accelerate and move to what's
known in urban planning theory as
the polycentric city polycentric city
would be a place where
you can work you can live you can
recreate
you can have your social life your
family
in a more local and distributed way in
cities like paris it's known as the
15-minute city
where daily necessities are within a
15-minute reach on foot or by bike
you reduce transit times you reduce ghg
emissions
and also you provide more equitable more
sustainable access to services by this
more distributed city model
but that's not to say that you need to
live in the suburbs right
so what's to say the office can't come
closer to us
i think going forward companies will
need to
support workers in that externality um
and it could take many forms does
everyone want to work from home
no some people like going to a place
commuting
how are companies that usually would say
come to your our main office
oh now actually we have a set of
sponsored co-working spaces across the
city that are closer to where you live
and can decrease your commute and maybe
you go to those spaces
three days a week and you come into the
office too i think we're going to see
a whole range of new types of work as
people have gained confidence
in the efficiency of work from home
during this time
[Music]
since the virus outbreak serviced office
brand regis has
already seen a surge of more than 40 in
activity
in new york city commuter hub southern
connecticut
in the uk house builders are seeing
developments outside of london
driven by a change in home office
working
while experiences and jobs vary all over
the world
many workers have come to expect change
more than 90 percent of people in a
recent survey said they wouldn't return
to the office full time after covid
there's reasons for employers to embrace
the change too
some already are twitter and facebook
have said the switch could become
permanent for large parts of their
workforce
the covert 19 pandemic has sent shock
waves through the world of work
having an on-off relationship with the
office could make us happier
and more productive while also helping
the environment
and making our cities more livable
you